privilege to have the health secretary
in the uh
studio for us this morning mr hancock
good to see you last time you were here
it wasn't this fancy new set it was the
old one
um you've got a fancy new app how does
it
behave as opposed to the old and why is
it so much better well we're launching
today
for the first time the covert 19 app for
england and wales
this is going to be a helpful tool to
to to help all of us to tackle the virus
and it it does the core job
of ensuring that if you've been in close
contact with somebody who
who's tested positive then you will be
notified
but it also will allow us to
to click on a qr code for instance when
you go to a to a restaurant
and to also find out what the rules are
in your area because we're increasingly
using
local action in parts of the country
where we need to take a stronger action
so it's got the details of that so
it's it's an information device it helps
you to record
where you've been which is important for
contact tracing and it has the core
capability
of letting you know if you've been in
close contact with somebody who's tested
positive what percentage of the
population needs to download it in order
for it to be effective
well there isn't a figure for that every
single person who downloads the app
is helping to improve how it can keep us
safe it helps you to keep yourself and
your loved ones safe
and every additional person downloading
it will
make the country a safer place but only
four percent of the population download
it's not going to work is that so you
must have a
a number no on the co on the contrary if
even if only two people downloaded it
and they came into close contact and one
had tested positive
then it would work for the other so the
more people it's true that of course the
more people who download it the more
effective it will be
but this is just one one part of our
overall plan for tackling coronavirus of
course
and so the more people who download it
the more effective
but uh according to report in this
morning's times uh 30
of test results uh give false positives
so 30 percent of people
could be self-isolating who don't need
to well that's not quite right
because the the app will
only tell you to self-isolate if you've
been in close contact with somebody
who's tested positive yeah but
they could be false positives well you
will have had to be in close contact
with somebody
for it to tell you to self-isolate so
there is a
the question of how long you've been in
that close contact is something where
we're
constantly improving the accuracy
but if you download the app and it comes
up and tells you to self-isolate
that is because you will have been in
close contact
with somebody yeah who but their test in
itself might have been a false positive
no only if uh no the the the the tests
that we have
have an incredibly incredibly high uh as
so this article this morning is wrong
well the question is
how close do you have to be for how long
and the app will not tell you
that you have to self-isolate unless you
have been in close contact with someone
we have in turn might have had a false
positive you know they might have gone
to have a test
and it they're told it's positive and
it's not and so the people around them
are being
told to isolate for a fortnight and they
don't need to but the proportion of
people who've had a who
for whom the test gives a positive when
they haven't had coronavirus is
is very very small that's not that's
underwater
okay okay where are we as far as testing
is concerned
um apparently positive tests up a
quarter yesterday and boris johnson
keeps telling us that
we're testing more than any other
european country how does it help
oh well the the the massive testing
capability that we've got
helps to find where the virus is so
if you think about it yesterday we had a
figure that there's over 6 000 people
who've tested positive in the in the
previous
24 hours and that as you said in the
report is comparable to the highest
levels
in the peak in terms of the number of
people who were tested positive
but back then we estimate through
surveys
that over a hundred thousand people a
day were catching the disease
but we we only found around six thousand
of them
and they tested positive now we estimate
that it's
under 10 000 people a day getting the
disease that's too high
but it's still much lower than in the
peak and we
through the mass testing that we have
the the to
the uh capacity quarter of a million
capacity that we have
we find we found yesterday over six
thousand of them
and that then allows us to and to do the
contact tracing
for everybody who tests it positive and
find who they've been in contact with
okay and in addition from today with the
app if
if you know if you download the app
you'll also have that added protection
for you and your loved ones okay 124 of
those were at
glasgow university one wonders why
you are focusing particularly on pubs
with a 10 p.m
pub curfew when actually it's kids
gathering
in universities or schools where the 21
of outbreaks are amongst school children
and universities only 5
in food outlets which is pubs so aren't
we targeting the wrong areas
uh well no if you look at the the
information that we get from contact
tracing because we
are in contact with all of those 6 000
people who
who test positive we try to get in
contact with all of them and we get in
contact with around 80
of them and so we've we can find out
where they've been
having contacts and we know
that the most likely places in your
household
and that's why in the areas and not in
pubs
and then in uh social settings but not
according to public health england's
figures 729 outbreaks to the week
ending 13th of september 5 in food
outlets which includes pubs and
restaurants
21 in schools 45 percent in care homes
well that's a slightly different measure
that's a measure of where there are
outbreaks
so for instance if a school has a
suspected case
then they will call public health
england in england or they'll call the
public health authorities in
in scotland for instance the university
of glasgow example
and that is then put down as an outbreak
that is different to measuring by by
contacting all the people who've tested
positive and finding out
where they have had close contacts that
way
we find where most of the contacts come
it's very complicated isn't it
i mean the problem is that we're
concentrating on the scientists and not
the economists and as a result
tens of thousands of people hundreds of
thousands of people are going to lose
their jobs what is your colleague which
is
not going to do today to protect those
jobs well throughout this kay
we have put enormous amounts of effort
into
protecting the economy as and people's
jobs
what are we doing going forward well the
chancellor is going to set out the
details
in their house of commons later and i'll
i'll let that be more targeted
well what you've seen is over the past
nine months since this crisis started
you've seen an unprecedented amount of
economic support to keep jobs going to
support businesses who have been
terribly hit by this and we're
determined
that that should continue so in the same
way that in
the last couple of weeks i've set out a
winter plan for the nhs a winter plan
for social care
the chancellor will be setting out the
winter plan for the economy
to support the economy going through
this look the whole principle of that's
been more targeted though doesn't it now
you know it was a blanket
at support uh in march and early april
that we heard
that cannot continue because we we we
will be keeping people
in jobs where the jobs we're just
propping them up against the window
basically
we need to be much more targeted and and
um areas like the aviation industry is
literally
on its knees again with the hospitality
industry well if you're gonna have to
help them specifically
well the the health measures that we're
taking are more targeted than they were
yeah i'm asking you about
your colleagues i know um i know and
he's gonna set out the details later
but what i'd say is that our whole
strategy is to suppress the virus whilst
protecting
education and the economy and
the the amount of work that's gone into
ensuring that schools can go back
that has gone successfully and we
protect people
in schools is including with the
outbreak management that we were just
talking about
and the chancellor has done i think
unprecedented amounts to support the
economy
and he'll be setting out the next steps
later can you acknowledge
at least that it's only just in the nick
of time that you are moving into place
some might say too late
to protect jobs given the um numbers
that we're looking at 695
000 fewer people employed in august
compared to march
well we've said throughout that
sadly we're not able to protect every
job
and every business but i think in terms
of the timing of this
we've been working on the winter plan
for the economy and
and options in case cases started to go
up again
since the summer and with the prime
minister having set out the
the what the next steps in terms of on
the health side
on tuesday now the chancellor is coming
to the house
on today two days later to set out the
the economic package but you know
my my um viewers watching this morning
very keen
when you were on lots of messages saying
can you ask him this can you ask him
that a lot of people worried about their
jobs what's the word about i understand
that but they're worried about
their jobs and they need to know as they
rush out the door this morning
will they still have a job in a month's
time and in order to do that they need
support from the government not just
health support from you but also
that's right from um your colleague
grisha's tonight that's right is it
going to be
targeted support for people like the
aviation industry and people like the
hospitality industry
and the night time industry if you don't
support them very soon
there will not be a nightclub to go to
or a pub to go to
or a plane to get on well as i say
the the health measures we're taking
have been more targeted
both regionally or locally
and or depending on where the virus is
spreading fastest
and in terms of the parts of life that
we
are having to put rules in place for um
to try to restrict the spread
i understand and and i i totally
understand
the challenges on the economic front i
mean that's my background before i came
into
into politics i totally understand that
and the chancellor and i work
incredibly closely together on this so
you know what he's going to say and
actually he
you know he comes from an nhs background
i come from a small business background
we understand where they are
where where the both the economic and
the health impacts
have you given advice well look we talk
all the time but
i'm the chancellor will set out the
details later today we'll have to
uh you know let's wait until then to uh
to see the details of it but the
principle is really clear which is that
we'll
support as much as is feasibly possible
people
through these what we know are very
difficult we'll go as we can see um
two quick questions before i let you go
um apparently there
are problems with the flu vaccine not
enough flu vaccines available
and so um chemists and gp surgeries are
having to ration them is that right
well we have record amounts of flu
vaccine in the country
i'm also very pleased to see that having
launched the flu
program this week we have record amounts
of demand for it that is a very good
thing
and in the first instance the flu
vaccine must go
to the clinically most vulnerable which
is the over 65s and those with other
health conditions but an answer to my
question but then we intend
then we intend to roll it out more
broadly after that yeah but do we have
enough
uh we've got more than we've ever had
before do we have enough well
if every single we have 30 million doses
under do we have enough well i'm
answering the question we have 30
million doses that is
more than enough for all the people who
are vulnerable
specifically vulnerable to flu to
get their doses and once we have
got the doses as much as possible to the
most vulnerable
then we will roll it out to to others
for instance of working agencies have
more supplies by then
we've got well we've got the record
amount of supplies but you'll totally
understand kay
that given that we have 30 million doses
i want to make sure that they are
available to the people for whom flu
can be a that can can kill
and after that we'll make it available
to the to those
uh for instance of working because i
mean dominick rob sat here yesterday he
said he was having
his flute job on friday i mean i'm
guessing he's not particularly
vulnerable
well lots of people are able to uh to
get
flu jabs uh and uh if they are if
they're in the categories that are
available
where they're available he's high risk
but there we are he'll have to
answer for that um and very quickly
before i let you go um
maybe you'll need to cover the
children's ears at home this morning um
how long is this casual sex ban going to
last you're saying that no social
distance is needed in established
relationships
what about people who are not in an
establishment why am i whispering i
don't know
i don't know you're you're live on
national tv um the
um uh look there are it's okay to smile
in these in these rules that we have to
bring in you have to have
there have to be boundaries
to kind of phrase that we have to if
you're saying that the the two
households shouldn't mix which we
are in some parts of the country uh in
the north the northwest in scotland in
parts of
wales uh then you you have to then
define
what is the boundary of that and that
does lead to something that's like
that i mean you know establish
relationship does that mean if i say i
love you because some people say that
and they don't mean it but
are you in an established relationship
then i don't know i think i think we
should
stick to the uh the the letter of it
which is that
uh it's it's okay in an established
relationship i think
what it i mean i know what it means to
you and mrs hancock that was exactly how
i was going to answer it
i know that i'm in an established
relationship okay what about other
people watching this morning
how would you define an established
relationship i think people
what it just means that people need to
be careful right people need to be
sensible
and if you're in a relationship that is
uh
that is well established you know that's
that's what like six months
what it means is not uh people be
realizing that by when you've had
by coming into close contact with people
like
other households then that is
how the virus spreads and
i just come back to the first principles
right which is we
all want to keep this virus under
control
we all need to play our part and playing
our part
involves following the social distancing
rules
and from today downloading the app that
is part of doing your bit
and it means abiding by these rules in
their letter and their spirit and if we
all do that then we'll get through this
as best we possibly can
and your body's worth the established
relationship haven't you because you
don't really know what that means
anybody can bend the rules on that can't
they i wouldn't suggest that i wouldn't
suggest bending the rules i would
suggest sticking to the
letter and spin okay it's good to see
thank you very much indeed for joining
us doing a great job thanks a lot